but number fourteen his big makes it a
three-possession game toy Craig Cantor
ran over Atari Craig and hit him in the
in um in the head again Gary Harris
coming up on in his Cantor now the
benches at least the coaches coming out
trying to make sure the benches don't
empty it has been sold physical all game
and finally just spills over now as Tori
Craig
hit the deck Gary Harris coming up on in
a scanner it's after the made free throw
here you're gonna see he just peels out
and runs into him I don't think that
eNOS was captain wasn't trying to really
digest that's coming he just kind of
walked into him I don't think that was
intentional at all but you know Tory
Crais got a broken nose any kind of bump
to that face hurt so badly Jamal
Murray's jumped up in his girl and said
hey man leave my guy alone he's battling
I he was a broken nose I love it I love
when the intensity gets like this this
is playoff basketball baby game - mmhmm
well yeah you know it hasn't been game
one was kind of a pretty game right a
lot of shots being made that good flow
to it this has been equally as
entertaining but it has been in the mud
you don't think this is pretty I think
this is absolutely a solid ten the more
I hang out with you the more I agree
with you but I can't I agree with you
all Tanner he's just sprinting back down
the floor yoga kind of pumped so many
stumbles a bit tied up and then Harris
in there to protect his teammate it out
respect that too
[Applause]
yeah absolutely now couple guys coming
off the bench to see yesterday exactly
actually Canada he did he got pushed by
yogic yeah I didn't see that from the
other angle yeah yoga just pushed him
into um playing Gary Harris wouldn't
have known that but I think a bigger
story right now is how many players came
off the bench he saw all the assistants
trying to do their job to make sure
their players don't come off the bench I
think was the timeout situation was
called so I think everybody was stuck
you know milling out on the floor for
the time on they're usually a little bit
more they're a little bit more lenient
when it when the timeout is called there
I was a little more lean on that
yeah Yoga definitely did shelf cancer
yeah so the timeout was yeah it's called
right after that collision there on the
floor before anything's happening as you
can see Turner though